I wasn't really planning to do a segment
about this but there have been so many
bad takes coming from I guess what we're
calling the revolutionary left that's
the non pejorative term that we've I
guess agreed on to describe them about
the resignation of Bolivian President
Evo Morales that I feel compelled to
discuss it because the right is just
completely uninformed about Latin
American politics so I really don't have
any message for them but there are a lot
of people on the left that are either
misunderstanding or just wrong in their
conclusions about what has taken place
in Bolivia over the last close to 15
years calling it in completely black and
white terms a military coup so my goal
here is to go through the whole story
hopefully this will be enlightening I
know I'll be called the shell and all of
this stuff but who cares right I mean we
we get one shot at doing things the way
we actually see them you only live once
and I'm gonna do the stories with the
nuance that I think they deserve because
that's really what's missing the problem
is there is too much black and white
thinking in general in politics people
are either good or bad the military is
either good or bad
socialism is either good or bad a
politician is either a savior or a
villain and I know lots of people who
work in the field of mental health and
they tell me you know a lot of the
people that come in that I see they have
in their lives all sorts of different
things going on that at the Rueter often
caused by black and white thinking about
gray areas in life about jobs about
relationships about their childhood
whatever and I believe that the same is
happening in politics and precipitable
Livius situation so let's try to put
that aside let's just all talk like
reasonable people
no one's chilling here some people may
be missing some of the facts some people
may be coming to conclusions that are
tinged by ideology let's not make these
umbrella black and white declarations
and let's try to actually figure out
what's going on so the Bolivian
President Evo Morales was first in
office in 2006 a few days ago he
resigned at the request or demand of the
Bolivian millet
Terry and request or demand we can argue
about but it's that not actually the
most important thing why did this happen
a few days ago there has been rampant
speculation about the most recent
election of being a bogus election the
Organization of American States put out
a report saying that the election
results were manipulated including
alterations forced signatures and wide
scaled data manipulation now there is
already a debate about this well does
that mean the election was bogus or are
these just reports of irregularities
like you have in many elections
including here in the United States but
for me the real story is actually bigger
than this and I want to ask you this
hypothetical if Donald Trump during his
second term imagine he gets reelected in
November and he gets a second term
imagine that during that second term
Donald Trump changed the constitution to
allow a third term effective immediately
but then also claimed that since the
Constitution was changed his second term
is sort of really his first term under
the new constitution so he should
actually get two more and then during
the third term which is really his
fourth he loses a referendum to allow
unlimited terms and then his Supreme
Court justices that he has selected say
forget about the term limits you can
stay as long as you want wouldn't we in
that situation as progressives who are
for the rule of law wouldn't we be
begging someone to force Donald Trump
out okay now let's talk about what
happened in Bolivia Evo Morales was
elected in 2006 and people were excited
because there were good things about his
election he is not it's not black and
white
he was the first ethnically indigenous
president of Bolivia that's great in a
country that has such a large indigenous
population why did it take so long to
have an indigenous president fantastic
lovely he reduced poverty during his
first term he offered a much more
sensible and pragmatic version of the
socialism that has been espoused by Hugo
Chavez and Nicolas Maduro he invested in
infrastructure and development and grew
the middle class great
but like with many of these
latin-american socialists of the last
many decades he's a increasingly
authoritarian there's corruption he was
elected to a five-year term in 2006 he
got a new constitution adopted while he
was president which allowed two terms
then in 2009 he called for early
elections one and said hey this is sort
of really like my first term because I
didn't complete the first term under the
old Constitution we have a new
constitution so I should really be able
to run again in 2014 it's not
objectively bad to change a constitution
but one should not be allowed to stay in
office longer than they were originally
supposed to because if change is made
under their watch that's what
authoritarians do so this is already bad
he wins that early 2009 election calls
it his first term so now he's allowed to
run again in 2014 and a court
increasingly under his control says yes
he is allowed to run again this will
count as his second term not as his
third or his first term not as a second
he barely wins in 2014 and then says
well let's do a referendum to abolish
term limits altogether so that I can
just continue being reelected and
reelected indefinitely voters reject
that referendum in Bolivia so what does
he do he appeals once again to a
Constitutional Court filled with people
loyal to him who say yep you know what
running for office is a human right in
Bolivia term limits violate the human
rights of a motorist so he can run again
which he does and wins in adult in an
election determined to have significant
irregularities but some characterizing
it as completely bogus so listen do I
want the military to take control of the
country now he'll know I'm from
Argentina I know what happens when the
military takes control it's bad is this
a black/white military coup no that's an
extraordinarily myopic interpretation
that completely ignores history in
Bolivia for the last 13 years if an
American president did 25% of what more
arrested in the election system in
Bolivia we'd all be
ending their removal you'll hear
comments like well this all happened
because American banking and Finance has
ruined these countries including Bolivia
how does that force a president to
change the Constitution to remain in
power longer and how does it excuse it
these things are not as cut and dry as
the revolutionary left is making them
out to be so my request to you is don't
fall for the black and white thinking
and of course the revolutionary Left
will say anyone who is not loudly
opposed to this is a pro military coup
pro-american interventionist Yankee
shill let's be adults guys give me a
break
the world is not black and white the way
you make it out everyone at lists did
some good things early in his presidency
he also is corrupt we are also seeing a
lot of the same things happen in Bolivia
that we have seen happen in other places
in Latin America like Venezuela and
others when these authoritarian leaning
socialists remain in power for longer
and longer periods of time now
interestingly the left and right share
the existence of these factions who
suffer from black and white thinking on
the right you have these libertarians
and small government people who think
their black and white principles tell
them everything they need to know on the
Left you've got the revolutionary left
who suffers from you know a version of
the same affliction where they see a
situation and they say oh yeah the
military's involved so it's bad and a
socialist is the president and that's
good and he's an ethnic minority so
that's that's it that's the analysis and
anything else is completely unacceptable
you're pushed out if you don't fall in
line with that ideology tell me all the
ways I'm wrong on the facts I'm ready
for it but let's not play these just
completely toxic black and white games
that unfortunately are happening among a
contingent of the left